Okay, so I guess maybe like um let me just tell you the topics I wanted to understand uh about like the donor side. One is about like how we get donations and maybe like similar to what we discussed, like how we get donations how, we capture the record if at all, like and then how do we then reach out to the donors and how do we like make reports of like um how ma how many donations we
and that kind of stuff. So maybe you can just first walk me through the basic process and then I can ask some like specific questions.
So uh we'll start with the category that what kind of donors we have. Uh we have major four kind of donors, okay. So there are individual donors like, people like you or people like me who contribute some you know maybe one time on daily basis or once in a month like that, right. So individual donors major are part of our beneficiaries, right. So someone told that I would like to donate, they will donate. But the challenge here is that then there is no touch base between them and
other than we send them email like happy santranti, happy new year, things like that right, Then there are individual donors who know about our work. Our friends and families have told them or they showed in press that hey I would like to donate do you know some NGO or some companies doing a good work. So these are the individual donors. And then we also reach out to people in corporates, in other societies, in other community that hey why don't you donate to first. So they are part of the individual donors. In individual donors
or even the corporate as part of individual? Okay.
corporate what we do is like employee engagement, right. So that employee giving they're also individual donors at a time. So let's say you work at META you will have some employee give that part. So we take it as an individual donors, but through companies, right. So these are the individual donors. And then uh in individual donor we have different categories. So there are donors who are have donated five laps and more than that.
Okay. This is the lifetime total donation? Okay.
So they become big donors for us potential, big donors for like w we say them H_N_L_s high, net worth in the mutuals, right. Because for them we have an acknowledgement process we, have this wall where we keep their name. And if someone contributes five laps once in a lifetime or even they contribute slowly and then it accumulate as five laps they, become big donors for us H_N_L_s, high, net worth in the mutuals.
this just raised one question was how do you know this how do you know who is the I s suppose I donated um one lakh two years ago then, I donated two lakhs then, I donated like another two lakhs how, would you like add up all those donations or something.
Right. So we have not missed any anybody tell now but there is a high chance that we can miss if we start accumulating and all that, right. So every month
you basically like periodically you manually reconcile and try to see like okay got, it got, it got, it got, it got, it. And you have all the records in your Excel fields, okay, yeah.
comes the corporate
corporates me in India uh you m you must know that for corporates it's a law right now it's an act that, C_S_R_, so we try to tap in the those C_S_R_s to get the C_S_R_ funds because, that is huge right, ten lakhs twenty, lakhs thirty, lakhs one, lakhs two, hundred and three crore right, that. So our major donations in hundred rupees fifty, five rupees come from C_S_R_s..
but we also get one lakh two, lakh ten, lakh or different uh uh category right, and then fifty five percent is that and then these are the individual donors then, we have second floor. So second floor uh I don't know we charge we take donation to give them individual rooms. So we have eleven individual rooms. They also become our individual donors at the end but we get seventy eight percent of total hundred percent donation from that room also.
Okay. So individual corporate private rooms?
Yes private, rooms and um other film profits like you know uh let's say um uh uh how should I say like, Reliance. So they wi that's a corporate but they will have their own money also, right?
Okay.
So we also try to target people who have money like individual donors again but uh at a higher level like they will give forty lakhs fifty, lakhs on their way a, one or five lakhs ten, lakhs again individual but category of H_N_I_s and all that corporate individual rooms and we get some income from those two coffee houses uh coffee places which we have rented out. That is also part of the donation.
to use them or save it or make a different deposit or something like that. So these are our potential though, like uh donation from their media. Uh that's it, yeah.
make the record of it. Like so one way is I know that well first of all uh you have U_S_ and India, right? Like are these completely separate?
Completely separate yes,
Um so when you report like the total donations you, never like add them up together, just completely separate organizations. Oh okay,
have done is two years uh before.
So everything we are routing it through on-line so that these are not proper proper documentation right, And India it's mandatory to give a A_D_G_ re receipts, so it's more than two thousand rupees. So in U_S_ now you will not have all those regulations but, it's very easy yeah, pay. So you just add your contribution here right, and then the receipt is immediately generated and it goes to the uh
say you want to donate one day uh medicine right, So I just have ten thousand rupees ach, we have this.
Or I mean you can just tell me like w what happens uh so can I like pay with U_P_I_ or like a okay.
uh thing. Earlier people used to donate hundred rupees, then we used to generate receipt personally, we used to write, we used to email them, scan thems, email them right, Right now it's automated. You add your donation here, you click pay now, donate now, and then there you they give you option like credit card, debit card, U_P_I_, bank transfer anything, 'cause then the money gets deducted from your account, and you get a receipt the email I_D_ which you have given.
Okay.
automatically and we also get a notification that hey I see this person has donated this bus and receipt has been generated.
Okay and then do you save that information somewhere?
Yes after that what happens is we have a dashboard so, this platform is known as Dana-Mojo.
Say it again?
Dana-Mojo D_A_M_A_, Dan.
It's a donation platform okay,
So this is a third party uh service which we have paid actually, it's known as Dana-Mojo D_A_M_E_M_O_J_ right, then what al then it goes to the account stream right, they download the dashboard every day because they have to reconcile the bank statement right, that we have received itna sti uh money this day. Now who has given? They do that uh uh the they generate that account stream does that.
Every day or once a week or so? Okay.
Yeah. Yeah.
But everyone they try to uh they come side right, So they will download that Excel. So major donation will come from that Excel right, Now we have different mechanism like bank transfer. You did a bank transfer directly to our bank. Now we don't know who are you right, Like who has donated. Some people inform us, some people don't inform us. They just do it and they don't inform us. But what I do is now where I come in I'll check with the team, hey do you know that somebody has donated this much
yesterday any potential person you know who may have done. Then if they know yes, so then I go back to the team, I check with them, if I get some information, I call them, then I collect all the details with them like pan number address, everything, then we generate the receipt, then I generate the receipt and we send it to over the email. So receipt generation also happens here in in the Dana mojo dashboard we have an option.
Dana mojo?
online this, is the only way. Then
Suppose like I tell you right now, like hey I wanna donate to you, like you would you tell me you can go with this? Like can't you show me a Q_R_ code that I just scan? Sorry?
That Q_R_ also be leading you to this platform, hey?
No, like a Q_R_ code that just opens my phone pay app and like you
So the p challenge with that is you can do that, but right now as a trust we decided that let's not do that, why? Because we don't know who are donating.
Wha uh do you always need to know who's donating?
Yes, because if that a because you become an anonymous donor if I don't know that you have scanned the Q_R_ and you have donated, right?
I think you still get their name like in phone pay like I'll get
You will get phone number sometimes, you don't get that also. In U_P_I_ that is the challenge. So I'll show you the statement maybe if next, it's great. So let me
phone pay app like I mean I don't use it that much, but here okay yeah I paid this Uber driver, these two Uber drivers I paid, it says nothing. Oh okay.
No.
No, you don't get printed card or debit card, right? And if you
So basically your constraint is that every time you collect a donation you have to collect their like in okay but, why?
So in India what happens is if your anonymous donation for whom we don't have any details, especially the band number, it's taxable. If it crosses five percent more than your total donation. Even for non only for non-profits. Yeah.
To collect all those.
But I think the trade-off is that you're increasing the friction of donating uh like I'm pretty sure a lot of people will go to this website and then they'll be like hey this is just too complicated I. can't figure it out. So you would have to uh like make some assumption about look if we made it easier to donate we might get like ten percent more donations, but then you might lose some because of so yes it's a complicated question.
And non-profit in India is being seen like some chores, right. So even your d anonymous donation increases people start questioning about. So what we can do is that uh so what also we can do is that five percent let us connect anonymous, and when it reaches that five percent will start. So that is one way to go ahead.
It it does.
Because we did the calculation right, from last two to three years we automated this platform two years b t March twenty twenty four. Before that our anonymous donation was like eight percent, nine percent, seven percent, because we did not know how to donate to.
Okay so if it's nine percent, that means you have to pay tax on the full nine percent or just the four percent above the five percent?
On that nine percent.
It's not just the four percent that's exceeding the oh okay, okay fair,
So then uh like both decided by not to ask donations. So we always try to collect even though we have automated this, as of now we have three percent of anonymous donations.
How?
People have details they just go they just donate they, don't want us to know who they are. And even we have phone number we call them they, don't share because they are not comfortable in sharing meetings. So those things are there.
To give you like uh checks right, like yeah.
Actually um for to make my donation online if it's non-anonymous, what all details do you mean?
You can't do online non-anonymous, you have to add your pan number, bank information. Then you have to do a bank transfer you, go. No no no no no, sorry. Then you have to go there, add your pan number, your name gets auto-populated, your add your address, uh email I_D_, contact number, uh all the s yes. So pan and address is mandatory.
See email e we need because we need to send the uh receipts, right? Because there is a platform, then phone number
Ask you a question like hey can you give me a list of the top hundred donors um from the past ten years, like how would you do something like that?
The past tenth I don't have, but again I will go back to the Excel. I will take all the so every year what we do is we reconcile donations who have contributed five lakhs and more than that because we need to update the name here. So I can give you from last five years I have
we go back to the donation sheet.
We see who has contributed large amount we, add to the current sheet.
What is the definition of large amount?
Like five lakhs and more than that. And the donors who are uh single or double also, so we need to do something like you know uh give me the double entries like you know uh uh duplicate. So let's say we come ten times right, ten thousand per month, so it's one lakhth.
My whole process we do yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So then um yeah, so then what do you do once you identified all the five lakhs plus?
Then then we on go down the tree of kindness thing, that hey these are the new donors which has to be installed newly or elevated uh elevated as in you go to the next static leave, it happens. So we do that. Then all donations which are on board, I cross it with the current sheet, current year donation, have they contributed again and then we add on that.
Okay, this is an annual activity. Okay. And uh what are the methods in which we try to do targeted fundraising?
So targeted fundraising, uh last two years we started one campaign known as known as Garden of Spash, right. So there what we did, whatever beneficial data info we had, right, we sent them works out that, become Garden of Spash, this manual, right. So everything is manual in donor English They. go meet them personally or we reach out through some lead connections. So for an example you work at Meta. So I'll tell Hey Nikhil, do you
somebody at in India who works at Meta will try to do some employee engagement programme. So we'll go if we get some connect, we'll go do some employee engagement programme, we'll ask them to contribute as a part of giving campaign, then we get from Beneventy that list and then
Raghu is doing that right, Like?
That's from the U_S_ part. So in India also we do. Let's say
Oh you, have Beneventy in India also? Oh okay, yeah.
Beneventy there are two ways, if somebody can donate to U_S_ first relative care also, and in India also. So we get to almost thirty forty lakhs ac uh this year twenty five lakhs we will get through Beneventy.
What's your annual like total donations like for last year? So thirty forty lakhs is like uh five per cent of that, like L_C_D_?
we did a targeted corporate reach-up. We went to Microsoft, we went to Google, we d so how we did was we started with living with workshop to enter corporate, and then we touch base to the employee engagement part, that you know this is a giving campaign, why don't you let us conduct some employee engagement part right, So at Microsoft we did that. So six hundred people did quit making work, personalizing, and we asked them to contribute that volunteering hours, right. So we
Mm-hmm.
two thousand per person per hour. So like that we collected eight and a half lakhs, then during living with workshop we requested Microsoft team to raise funds. So they said, see special office is doing very good job, why don't you contribute some money during that online hybrid workshop what we did. And then Google also we did the same thing, then at terra data companies like that. So we leased almost twenty twenty five lakhs like that.
are they like high net worth individuals like or like you said this corporate thing is just five per cent right, that sounds very small like weird.
Corporate giving campaign is five per cent. C_S_R_ is fifty five per cent.
Oh right, C_S_R_ is a big one, okay. And what's the other break down? Fifty s what per cent is that per cent?
How do you uh know these percentages by the way you, analyse that Excel sheet.
Uh then we'll have Excel right, I'll do individual individual individual corporate like this way. So C_S_R_ F_C_R_A_ um general donation is what individual donations and then corpus. Corpus is the savings.
One request I have at some point is like would you be able to share this Excel sheet with me like then that'll it'll give me an idea of like what kind of information we're we're capturing.
Excel part and then we have the same thing in time. That's the accounting side, so in that also you can see how many C_S_R_s have come, how many of them have come.
Okay.
Every individual on their base they keep doing it. And on let's say Michael's s grantee is there, so we have the email I_D_s right, So we'll send them hey happy Michael's s grantee, he is.
Sur-Mandal.
Mm-hmm.
out your app right now, scan this and you would probably get like at least some small pers so I for some reason I'm thinking there's just like high friction and one of the points you raised is absolutely this like information collection and stuff but maybe there are ways to make that easier like what if the Q_R_ code is not taking you to a payment link but like the first thing actually you need to do before um getting a donation is you need to make this
person like an interested person, and so what if the first step is instead of saying donate, there's like hey like subscribe here, and then they get added to your like mailing list or like campaign list and then you reach out like, s uh s
But if you if as you rightly put, if you get the donation at that time, you get the donation. If you tell them no, at least add your number or something they'll give you, then they'll never do it.
that easy if you're like hey just, scan this Q_R_ code and you'll
Then we give a pause for two three minutes, right? Like I have a Q_R_ code, I put up Q_R_ code, that is how we do Like. put the Q_R_ code. So Q_R_ code again that, we'll need you with that donation platform.
right, but I'm saying there could be other ways to do that. No no no no, like I'm saying like yeah.
add you to like a mailing list, and then y you you guys can do like some email campaigns every now and then to try and convert some of these like people who previously expressed the information.
Okay, so whenever Dr. Subraman goes to some rotary meeting and all that, he always add them gives, me ten name who are interested. So I keep calling them, I keep sending them lots of things. It doesn't that R_O_I_ is not safe.
Ottawa is high for you right now because it's a manual process and you're like hey for these ten people I'm spending like one hour chasing them and I got nothing but if the process was sure but if the process was automated then the Ottawa would be much higher because that investment is much lower then you're like hey this is just something in the background it's automatically happening it doesn't cost you anything so when my father goes and gets these ten names his job will be not to give you that list or maybe he gives you that list but
all you do is like you add those as entries into the system and like if it automatically it has some periodic like reminder system, it's like basically lead capture, like in these are leads, and then you have a system that intelligently figures out like uh what frequency to reach out to these leads and how to like target them or something like that.
the donation at the right, the same moment till you get it. That is like uh look we have seen that you know, like we did a lot of campaign in last week. Obviously I'm not denying that fact that we should not have a lead capture and sending that thing. But what I'm trying to say is that when you see the thing right, that time you are very high on energy and you feel very positive about it and then you just do the donation in the moment.
Yeah.
you're like first there's like awareness and then consideration and then they make the purchase or action. So some people will be ready like right then to do it. But there are some people who are just like not ready right now and so we need a way to capture both, like whoever is ready to make the donation. Yeah. And that's similar to what we were who was our names? Is this similar to what we were talking about? They're also like some kind of lead capture and all those just
If we can use the lens.